who who for you as a woman who's a
positive uh role model as a woman that's
well known who do you look at as a woman
that's successful and and has the
lifestyle you want
and the family you want and the marriage
you want who who do you look up to as a
woman what are you starting over here I
think that's really hard because you
really you don't really know people's
life you really you're not with them day
to day I mean what looks good on
Instagram and what looks good when
they're in an interview is one thing but
what's actually going on behind closed
door is very totally different like
everybody wants a happy relationship
right no one goes into it saying I want
a terrible relationship I want to argue
at least once a week I want to do this
even though that's the reality those
things are going to happen but it's how
you handle those disagreements how you
handle those arguments or you want to
call them a [__] ass [__] or are you
going to say something like you know
what my apologies you know whatever the
case may be so I don't think that I
don't look up to anybody because I don't
I realize that I don't know people's
real relationships and I always that's
why I always ask like the question like
will you obey your husband because that
really kind of tells you where someone's
mindset's at like could he tell you to
shut the [__] could he could he no but
that's that's wrong it's like
the [__] up if he is a boss ass [__]
it says in the Bible that your husband's
supposed to love you right and he
doesn't say love you when you're being a
perfect feminine woman most of us most
women today we're not perfect feminine
women yet we ask the men to be these
perfect leaders and will only obey them
when they're leading perfectly they're
not always going to lead perfectly life
is long but but the question is like and
then and then we get these like church
it's so stupid they they put propaganda
in the church in the early 1900s to
influence women that's why you have all
these single women in churches basically
saying that like you can only submit to
your husband's Authority when he follows
God but then that puts the woman
deciding when he's following God and
when he's not following God but it's
like men have given us a lot of Grace
but we have no Grace for men
I was going to say I do um look up to
Jada and will believe me oh my God I
want to meet them I'm manifesting it I
think that they are so [__] cool
because they're open enough to
understand that sometimes you might have
attractions to other people and it's
okay to make these kinds of
relationships as long as you stay
Partners together if I ever do get
married I would never want to get a
divorce even if we live separately and
it what about you
I don't particularly have a like a
celebrity or anything that I'm looking
up to but just anybody like in your life
like maybe your grandmother or something
um yeah I don't really
really about either anyone else
I think Denzel and his wife seem to have
a pretty healthy relationship but I
don't know everything sure sure but I'm
talking about a woman a woman but I love
how like they're into charity how they
like how they're in the charity how they
might want to like build together
they're looked at like in another
platform I would love to be at that kind
of status I love the the relationship
and the camaraderie that they have with
each other I think that's very admirable
but again I don't know everything sure
it could be [__] horrible so my but
my point is is there's not a a figure
out there right it's installing positive
messages to to women I mean even Beyonce
I'm an independent I'm an it's like
right yes
[Music]
she's been married
that's my point you started off you're
telling all these women to be
independent and you've been married
she's the biggest
[Laughter]
well here's the thing even like a
relationship is when you go to work
there's rules right there's things that
you sign off to when you get employed to
say I will not do a b c d f and g
boundaries that's the same but when I
don't think people value that when
they're in a relationship because they
don't look at it as a job or a contract
but it actually is it's things in there
you're going to tell your man don't hit
me don't cuss at me or whatever your
boundaries are the things that make you
feel uncomfortable I did something you
know it's Alice is really interesting
um who who here is in a relationship
raise your hand
um three three okay it's it's
interesting because I can't I can't oh
my God I don't know what she's saying
it's interesting because I can't tell
the difference between women in a
relation and not in a relationship in
this room based on like how
provocatively like you guys are
addressed yeah and there used to be a
time where like when when you got
married it's like I can't even tell the
difference between the wives and the
mothers and the young women that are
single and signaling but you know you're
funny but wait a minute let me just cut
you off because I just told her I said I
wore a t-shirt here because I thought
there would be a bunch of men here but
when I found out it was majority women
in the room I took my shirt off and she
took her shirt off for me
do you know what's interesting about the
way you guys you know what's interesting
the way you guys process information is
you process it very personal where it's
like about you and I'm not talking about
any of you individually but I'm just
saying as a group like I can I walk down
the street and I'll see women holding
the hands of a guy dressed like a hooker
I'll see wives and mothers on Instagram
dressed like thirst traps and it's like
where are we as women in society if I
can't tell the difference
the guy that I'm dating said to me hey
when you are not with me or I don't like
that you dress like that then I would
change but but the thing is if there's
not an issue there's but the thing is
like men will study us to figure out
what we want and then adjust accordingly
like they'll be like okay like they
don't like it when women don't like when
we do this this and this type of Realm
not right I mean come on do you know
what you think we'd start by being in
shape like that's the one thing
so you're you're already processed
but I'm saying as a group 70 of us are
overweight let me tell you something
though they're the guys who are the most
in shape the buffest most [__] cut up
dudes like fat [__]
there's always some there's always going
to be someone there's always going to be
and see like it's like the personal
attack
people are married look at sometimes
sometimes but it's never it's never it's
never to the men that you want they're
always these dorky ass dudes
even if you're skinny it doesn't mean
that like all of a sudden a guy's gonna
fall in love with you and be right to
you like you're talking it no it doesn't
make it easier I am [__] hot as [__]
I don't give a [__] what anybody has to
say and I still deal with the [__]
because a guy's gonna do what the [__]
he wants to do because he wants to
um I never said that right remember and
I'm not going to it okay okay is this is
this guy hot
his girlfriend is super attractive
because he's a high-valued man and he
wants a fit feminine attractive woman he
paid 38 billion dollars to get a divorce
to be with a Latina news reporter who
looks like a model for him to die hold
on high value men want fit feminine
attractive women
So when you say well I know guys yeah I
know guys too that'll be with a a woman
that's overweight or obese but the point
is the guy the guys that most women go
after this guy's not attractive
right he was at 7-Eleven with a name tag
that said Jeff Bezos on it you wouldn't
take a second look you know what a lot
of women go after this guy why because
he's status because he has money
resources resources yeah that's my point
so when you talk to these guys we're all
the high value men they're with the
pretty girls they're the guys that have
the Monaco and the girls 19 21 years old
and she's got a brain of a box of rocks
she's not smart well and it's like if
women didn't know this it's like we
spend thousands of dollars on bbl's jobs
to look younger like it's like women
will spend money to look younger smaller
tighter they'll go to personal trainers
and say that men don't like what they
like
this is why like even though I don't
agree with you and I feel like a lot of
you the [__] you say is stupid I still
like you
because like
do like say a lot of [__] that I do
agree with and like people tell me I'm a
confused ass Republican all the time
they're like you believe in capital
punishment and [__] abortion and all
this [__] I'm like yeah but you know I
I'm not Republican uh you know it's like
you know just some [__] like that you
know women shouldn't vote yeah
[Laughter]
it's so it's so funny we'll have this
whole convo and like I think by the end
it's like I'm showing why we shouldn't
vote
It's like because we can't even we're
arguing about this water wet do men like
thin chicks
let's talk about let me ask you a
question you don't have to expose this
or not yes
did you all vote in the last election no
no I'm not gonna vote the next one
either yeah did y'all did y'all vote for
did y'all vote for Obama yeah yeah why
why because he's black but that's my
point
I voted because I don't want somebody to
run my country
oh my God okay wait wait wait wait what
do you think about the emotional part
when you're here yeah voting yeah you
need to think about what that person can
bring to the table
what can I just say that my my grandpa
always told me vote for what you need
don't vote for what other people okay
watch watch this first of all he's not
black he's biracial he is he's very
funny
second of all I have a dream that one
day my children okay will be judged by
their character not the color of the
skin
because he was black but that was big
feeling
Forum based on facts and that's the
point
the point I said that because I know a
lot that's the typical answer so
everybody normally says that however in
the black community when you have black
grandparents black mother black father
etc etc they tell you they explain to
you about Obama it wasn't just it was
somebody who you could relate to but you
finally but it wasn't just about his
skin color because we also voted for
Clinton we also voted Clint's black he
had a [__] in the office
white guys
I know
what get blow jobs in their [__]
office all day every day
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you don't think they would take it right
now
that's all guys that was a joke it was a
joke Clinton's black right
now
there you go that's what I was talking
about I don't know
y'all May hate women but y'all hate
black people
[Laughter]
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible